see how I substituted 54:49 which made
this thing smaller okay what I'm gonna
do is substitute 2 to the K for
something that I know is smaller than
that namely K squared okay you see 2 to
the K is bigger than K square this guy's
smaller when I put it in place here
let's actually write this in 2 lots of K
squared minus 2k plus 1 or squared the
reason this is advantageous to me is
that I could say oh this K squared is
smaller than this so you're ending up
this whole line is something smaller so
instead of the left hand side B equals
should write that the left hand side is
not equal to this it's bigger
do you see that this is really different
right we're changing an equation into an
inequality and the reason we could do
that is because we've made this
assumption in fact we need to say that
as well by assumption we can make this
statement because I've now by according
to the assumption made substituted
something bigger for something smaller
so now I've got a smaller result that's
why this is the smaller tip of things
okay now why might this be used for two
reasons number one I've used the
assumption we knew we're going to have
to use it at some stage but number two
see over here I no longer try to mix
together an exponential to the K with a
polynomial right I've got polynomials
and polynomials I've got Squared's this
is much easier to deal with so now I'm
gonna take Chloe suggestion before and
I'm going to expand this guy this is
going to be something that I can now
collect like terms really okay let's
have a look I've got two squared that -
affects everything that I'm about to
write so therefore we're going to get K
squared - 2 K minus 1 how's that look
are you happy with that now I can
collect like terms it's just the first
pair of terms there - K squared minus K
squared is that all right now at this
point again you're wondering well well
what am I supposed to go with this now
I'm going to do something in a second
that I know who'll look kind of like how
on earth did he think to do that okay
the short answer question is I've had
enough practice with these that I
realize this is a useful thing but by
the end of this we're going
come back to this line and I'm going to
try to help you work out why was this a
useful thing that I'm about to do I am
going to write this next line as instead
of writing minus one I'm gonna write
that minus one as plus 1 minus 2 plus 1
minus 2 now I heard this is weird you're
like why are you making things more
complicated okay we had like terms
collected why are you uncollected them
okay and the reason why is because when
you think about proving that something
is greater than zero things that you're
looking for are things like
Exponential's right that thing is bigger
than zero no matter what value of K you
put it it it also squares right when
you've got something squared these
things tend to be positive okay so when
I look at this guy here I can factorize
this can't I this guy is going to be K
minus one all squared okay now this is
useful to me because now I can actually
say see this left-hand side if it's
bigger than this if I can make a
statement about this if I can prove that
this thing is positive then I'm good to
go now remember I highlighted before see
this guy the guy we skip over so quickly
this attribute or this characteristic of
K is very important I'm going to use it
right now okay and I'm gonna highlight
it by putting it in a separate color for
you okay since I know that K is not just
a T number K has to be greater than four
I can say since K is greater than four I
can make some statements about this that
will be related to this for example I
don't have a k just by itself I've
actually got K minus one in there you
see that so if I subtract one from both
sides I'm getting three you hear that
now I actually don't just have K minus
one by itself it's been squared now
watch out I'm gonna write this next line
and then I want us to think about it
together
I just squared both sides but we just
talked before about the fact that you
can't just square both sides in
inequality except for when you can write
think about this right I gave you a
particular example that broke this where
you
square both sides what was it about that
example that made it problematic if the
answer is the negative right
sometimes you can't square both sides
for instance 3 is less than 4 that was
something we said earlier right if I
square both sides 9/16 is the inequality
that is still true the answer is yes
okay it's the negative the course the
problem and have a look here right when
you square this right hand side you're
multiplied by 3 is that okay it is right
it's a positive number
what about over here when you multiply
by K minus 1 again and I allowed to do
that and the answer is yes I can't cuz
look K minus 1 it's greater than 3 it
has to be positive right so this guy's
positive this guy's positive I can
satisfactorily square okay now and what
was there I don't just have K minus 1
squared all by itself I have K minus 1
squared minus 2 so I'm just gonna
subtract 2 from both sides that gives me
a 7 on the right hand side but look at
this thing right see this it's some
number it's greater than 7 if I asked
you all to think of a number that's
greater than 7 I could say with
confidence that all of the numbers you
just thought of they all have to be
bigger than 0 right if they're bigger
than 7 they have to be bigger than 0
there have to be positive now do you see
what we've just established this guy
here is here and I'm just showing hey
that guy there is greater than 0 right
like that's what we just established now
if Venus is bigger than this and this is
bigger than this it's like a big fish ad
a smaller fish which makes it even
smaller fish this guy clearly is bigger
than that one down the end so I can say
oh the left-hand side must be greater
than 0 itself what is the left-hand side
it's this right so 2 to the k plus 1
minus 1 we have K plus 1 all squared
just to make this nice tidy to be
complete I'm going to write it in the
form that I originally put it when I had
the k plus 1 statement right there so
this is it it's true I can write this
therefore it's true
for n equals k plus one particularly
breath and you can say at last I have
proven this this are true by the
principle of mathematical induction so I
do a lot of this feels quite weird and
unusual because the first time you've
seen a proof an inductive proof dealing
with these kinds of objects right can we
rewind for a second I told you before
that this step in here will look a bit
weird like why would I do that and the
answer was now that you see where I went
I was essentially doing something you
haven't touched for a while you thought
about it maybe within the context of
quadratics I was completing the square
do you see that that's what I did here's
this term I halved it and then I squared
it which gave me one but then I didn't
really want to change from line to line
if I don't have to it hurts my brain
would I do that swap a number for
something else just because I can
because of the inequality so to preserve
everything here plus one take away two
is the same as take away one so once
I've got that I've got something easy to
work with okay now you can prove this by
not method two which is making
everything greater than zero and then
going with that you can prove this by
starting from this statement but we'll
have a look a little bit later on at how
you do that